[Music]
on this wednesday night a controversial
app and your concerns about your
constitutional rights
alarm bells about arrive can it creates
direct harm for people who are receiving
this incorrect notification that calls
for greater transparency and
accountability
amber alert over where two missing
saskatchewan children were found in
their condition now
a social media activist targeted by
online harassers they want me dead her
wrongful arrest by police in ontario
and the rise of exoskeletons the sky's
the limit a bc man's sci-fi fantasy
becomes a reality
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight bara nasser
good evening thank you for joining us
the controversial arrive can app is
facing more criticism tonight since it
was launched in april of 2020 it has
sparked hundreds of complaints from
canadians it's been called unreliable
cumbersome glitchy and a barrier for
those who are technically challenged but
now there are concerns the app may be
violating canadians constitutionally
protected rights our mercedes stevenson
has more in our top story tonight
the arrive can app is the gateway to
canada no app no entry you're supposed
to be able to just fill out this form
and breeze through the border
a lot of tears
there's been a lot of fear
for no reason
but for thousands of fully vaccinated
canadians like katie lister glitches and
errors have resulted in false quarantine
orders with real impacts on their lives
getting daily
daily
three calls sometimes four calls a day
including human officers who've not even
taken the time to go into my phone and
be like oh shoot she's triple vaccinated
and she arrived on the 16th she's fine
it's not just about the stress
some data and privacy experts are
warning the app could be violating
canadians constitutional rights when it
fails and wrongly quarantines people
including the charter right to freedom
of movement
one expert thinks it could even rise to
the level of unlawful detention it
creates direct harm for people who are
receiving this incorrect notification
and following it and there's no law
professor charisma mathen has concerns
about app glitches it is an error so by
definition it's it's not a justified
infringement of your liberty but mathen
says because the government has taken
reasonable steps to try to resolve
erroneous orders she's not sure this
rises to the level of a charter rights
violation
a recent glitch affected approximately
ten thousand canadians wrongly telling
them to quarantine
global news has learned it took the
government nearly 12 days to inform
people of that air
the experience has left lingering fears
about the next border crossing for many
i'm fearful of
going back to my own country when i
shouldn't whatsoever um i i i you know i
have these questions global news spoke
with several canadians including katie
who struggled to talk to a human to try
to resolve the situation and pharah this
relates some of the big issues lack of
oversight and transparency the
difficulty getting an error fixed with a
person and the use of artificial
intelligence to make decisions about
something as major as a quarantine
without a human in the loop i ran into
this myself recently returning to canada
what was fortunate to have mine resolved
relatively quickly farah mercedes
stephenson and ottawa thank you mercedes
after a tense day and a half there is
good news to tell you about in the case
of an amber alert issued for two missing
children from saskatchewan last night
the kids were found safe in south dakota
while the man they were with a convicted
sex offender is now in police custody
global's troy charles has the latest
it was just after 7 p.m monday evening
when rcmp issued the amber alert for two
missing saskatchewan children ages 7 and
8. police were concerned because it was
believed the children were in the
company of a registered sex offender
fast forward to tuesday evening that
amber alert gets extended into south
dakota in the united states rcmp say not
long after that law enforcement
officials in south dakota were able to
safely locate the two children their
mother and 50 year old benjamin martin
moore in sturgis south dakota and just a
reminder we'll not be using any of the
names or images of the children in this
story to help protect their privacy
benjamin moore and the children's mother
were taken into custody by the meade
county sheriff's department in 2009
moore was convicted of sexual
interference with a minor and served two
years in prison saskatchewan rcmp had
issued a warrant for his arrest tuesday
for failing to report a change of
resident which is a requirement for
convicted sex offenders this ordeal
began august 5th after social services
asked rcmp to help with an investigation
into moore only to find their home in
east end saskatchewan abandoned rcmp say
three days later they received an
apprehension order from social services
and the amber alert was sent the group
was located some 600 kilometers south of
the canadian border in sturgis south
dakota currently being held in sturgis
is the sturgis motorcycle rally which is
a 10-day event that brings motorcycle
riders from across north america to
south dakota moore the two children and
their mother were found at a campsite
where many motorcycle rally attendees
were staying
the south dakota attorney general's
office says there is no indication of
any injuries and that the two children
are being cared for as preparations are
made to have them returned to their
rightful custodian surely a huge sigh of
relief for all those involved after a
scary situation ends with two children
avoiding any serious physical harm
troy charles global news
22 people were arrested and are facing a
string of more than 400 charges as
police in ontario dismantled a major
cross-border gun and drug trafficking
ring york regional police say the
investigation dubbed project monarch
began last october and in late july
search warrants were executed at two
dozen homes and businesses police seized
27 handguns along with more than 300
rounds of ammunition and high-capacity
magazines the guns are believed to have
been illegally brought over from the u.s
more than 1.3 million dollars worth of
cocaine heroin fentanyl and other drugs
were also seized
a popular transgender activist and
online streamer is speaking out after
being swatted swatting is when false
threats are made to police which trigger
armed officers showing up at the
unsuspecting victim's home
clara sorenti says that's exactly what
happened to her on friday morning
amir khan has more on her terrifying
experience and why she believes she was
wrongfully arrested
clara cerenti says a false email with
her address was sent to london city
council claiming she had killed her
mother and was intending to shoot people
at city hall who were straight the email
sorenti says had given out her real
address and resulted in police with guns
at her doorstep and her being arrested
when
i went into the hallway and then saw
that assault rifle i screamed and
i i thought i was going to die london
police service confirmed the arrest to
global news they added sorrenti was
released without charges and they are
continuing to analyze her electronic
devices but could not offer any more
information sorrenti says the hate she's
been facing is because of her prominence
as a trans woman and activist they want
me dead
because
i'm a high profile transgender activist
there's a big target on my back and for
the past year transgender people have
been at the focal point of a culture war
it's not just the doxing but torenti
takes issue with london police services
handling of the incident evidence bags
she showed global news indicates police
use her dead name the birth name she had
before transitioning which is considered
highly offensive she also claims police
asked her if she was a she and to
explain dead naming
the way that i was treated by the police
really showed me they know nothing about
transgender people or issues police told
global news that this is an active
investigation but despite being a
prominent name online and having run for
office provincially and federally
cerenti thinks police's actions are
driven by ignorance
so i had a hate crime perpetrated
against me and instead of the police
helping me
they victimized me for it as for the
trolls and hate mongers sorenti says she
remains undeterred i'm not backing down
i know that the work i do is incredibly
valuable
and thousands of trans people have told
me that i have people almost every day
saying they came out to their families
because of me
and
if they want me to stop the next time
they better manipulate the police into
pulling the trigger amar khan global
news london ontario
patience is wearing thin in newfoundland
and labrador as explosive wildfires keep
growing and a change in weather is
expected tomorrow with winds predicted
to shift as abigail beeman reports
people in nearby communities are now
being told to pack go bags and they're
being warned to be prepared and ready to
leave at a moment's notice
along the newly reopened bay despair
highway smoldering spots and burned out
brush the highway is open for now but
with the fires growing and winds
expected to shift from the southwest
everyone is concerned about thursday the
fact is that we have a fire that's over
17 000 hectares burning uncontrollably
25 kilometers from our community so
that's a serious situation warnings from
officials in grand falls windsor and
nearby communities have become stronger
the mayor wants everyone to pack a
so-called go bag full of essentials and
be ready to leave with an hour's notice
my bag is packed it's by the door
kennels are ready for the pets
snacks and stuff in the food are in the
car for the kids
but otherwise
just kind of carrying on as usual we're
just playing it day by day and like say
if we get the call to say that we have
to evacuate while we're ready towns have
been offering daily buses to transport
people who want to leave especially the
vulnerable to a shelter two hours away
but there hasn't been much uptake air
crews and ground crews were out all day
wednesday tackling three fires in
central newfoundland the biggest has
grown to 17 thousand hectares and
tuesday's rain wasn't enough the water
bombers in the paradise lake and bayless
barrier they're basically managing the
two of those different incidents because
they're really close in proximity so
if they see one flare up over on the
other side they'll go manage it
and move back and forth that way
officials believe the fires will grow
larger before they can get the upper
hand but they're confident they will get
them under control when the wind changes
tomorrow it's going to be
pretty smoky here so probably unbearable
in the meantime thousands of people are
living on edge abigail even global news
there's better news for those in bc's
southern interior some of the residents
ordered to flee a raging wildfire
received the all clear to return home
today
crews fighting the caramelous creek
wildfire and gaining the upper hand
thanks to calmer conditions in recent
days almost 500 properties remain on an
evacuation order and more than 900 are
on an evacuation alert the wildfire has
shrunk slightly to 6700 hectares but
lightning and strong winds expected to
arrive tonight could cause the wildfire
to erupt
an alleged assassination plot forwarded
coming up why police believe former top
white house advisers were targeted
the u.s justice department says it's
uncovered an international murder for
hire plot led by a member of iran's
islamic revolutionary guard the alleged
targets were members of then president
donald trump's cabinet an inner circle
as jackson prosko reports the plot's
believed to be retaliation for the 2020
assassination of a top iranian commander
it was a 2020 u.s drone strike that
killed top iranian general qasim
solomoni after the trump administration
claimed the leader of iran's
revolutionary guard was plotting to
attack u.s embassies by removing
solomani we have sent a powerful message
to terrorists two and a half years later
iran is allegedly still out for revenge
the u.s justice department says it
uncovered a plot by a member of the
revolutionary guard to murder former u.s
officials
they say the suspect based in tehran
attempted to pay 300 thousand dollars to
people in the us to eliminate former
national security adviser john bolton
and one million dollars for an
unspecified second job reports suggest
the target was former secretary of state
mike pompeo this is an especially
appalling example of the government of
iran perpetrating egregious acts of
transnational violence iran is a rogue
regime bolton was seen as one of the
most hawkish members of the trump white
house as architect of the maximum
pressure campaign he pushed to end the
iran nuclear deal
pompeo was secretary of state at the
time and insisted solemni posed an
imminent threat to the u.s qasim
suleimani himself was plotting a broad
large-scale attack against american
interest just last month a u.s
intelligence report warned iran was
still looking to avenge its slain
general and could target current or
former u.s officials up to and including
former president donald trump i
understand that iran does engage in this
sort of action and behavior and and it
does undercut security around the world
and now including in places like the
united states shocking but not
surprising the alleged plot may torpedo
last ditch efforts to salvage the iran
nuclear deal where one of iran's key
demands is removing the revolutionary
guard from the u.s terrorist blacklist
jackson prosko global news washington
and former u.s president donald trump
refused to answer questions from new
york prosecutors today repeatedly
invoking his fifth amendment right to
silence during a scheduled deposition
connected to an investigation into
whether the trump organization misled
tax authorities by providing false and
fraudulent financial statements trump
says he declined to answer the questions
under the rights and privileges afforded
to every citizen under the united states
constitution and as it turns out
monday's fbi raid at trump's mar-a-lago
estate may be a consequence of a bill
trump signed into law as president in
2018 making it a felony to mishandle
classified information
that law was created as a piece of
trump's campaign
against hillary clinton
ahead danger close the fears over
europe's biggest nuclear plant caught in
russia's war on ukraine
foreign ministers from canada and other
g7 nations have issued a joint statement
calling for russia to hand back control
of europe's largest nuclear power plant
to ukraine the calls come amid new
rounds of shelling both in the region
surrounding the plant and in
russian-occupied crimea signaling a
possible new front in the months-long
war
redmond shannon reports
ukrainian authorities say 13 people died
in air strikes on the city of marjanets
tuesday night just 15 kilometers from
europe's largest nuclear power plant the
site at zapparija has been occupied by
russia since march and has seen shelling
two including over the past weekend
both sides accuse each other ukraine
says russia is using the plant as a
cover to fire rockets with the potential
for a disaster far worse than the
chernobyl meltdown 36 years ago because
it's a normal it was only one unit
here you have six units six reactors g7
foreign ministers echoed un concerns
wednesday in a joint statement asking
russia to hand back control of all
nuclear power plants in ukraine saying
the occupation is significantly raising
the risk of a nuclear accident or
incident and endangering the population
of ukraine neighboring states and the
international community
meanwhile far behind russian lines in
annex crimea there is no finger pointing
about tuesday's huge explosions there
russia says it was just an ammunitions
accident at one of its airbases keeve is
saying little but reports wednesday
suggest ukrainian special forces were
behind the attack one that could mark an
important new front line in the conflict
president vladimir zelinski didn't
reference the blasts but he did issue a
new red line saying crimea must be
returned to ukraine if the war is to end
something he has previously stopped
short of doing redmond shannon global
news london
dozens of people are feared to have died
off the coast of greece after a boat
carrying as many as 80 migrants and
refugees sank overnight the coast guard
says 29 men were rescued after the ship
capsized and sunk near the southeastern
greek island of carpetos the rescued men
from afghanistan iran in iraq say the
vessel had left from turkey and it was
heading toward italy with 60 to 80
people aboard greece's navy and air
force joined rescue efforts but
officials say there has been no sign of
some 50 people who are still missing
dramatic new images illustrating the
increasing desperate drought situation
gripping large parts of europe the water
level on the rhine river has dropped so
low it's causing major bottlenecks and
it's forced some of the larger ships and
barges that ply the river to a
standstill the cost of delivering
freight on the river has increased
five-fold
near barcelona a 9th century church that
had been underwater for hundreds of
years has now re-emerged from a
reservoir in central spain the water
level in the cijara reservoir has
dropped to just 16 percent of its
capacity parts of the iberian peninsula
are at their driest in 1200 years
the future gears up next the bc man
turning a sci-fi staple into a real
competition
if you're a science fictioner chances
are you've dreamt of piloting a giant
robot well a bc engineer has got
something pretty close he and his firm
have already built the world's largest
four-legged exoskeleton mech suit and
they're just getting started as mike
drale reports they're hoping to create
one very metal sport
okay
see what you've got it's not difficult
to see where jonathan tippett drew the
inspiration for his exoskeleton
[Music]
who wouldn't want to pilot one of these
but oddly enough it wasn't movies that
got the mechanical engineers wheels
turning it was a 2003 trip to the
burning man festival in the nevada
desert there he looked at the giant
sculpture and said why not
we see a future or or imagine and
envision a future where
mech suits powered mech suits are as
common as atvs
almost 20 years after his burning man
inspiration the science fiction dream is
no longer fiction in fact at 4 000 kilos
and 10 feet tall his creation is now in
the guinness book of world records as
the largest tetrapod exoskeleton in the
world
it also
pointed to the fact that maybe we made
it a little too big
the next generation is going to be about
two-thirds the size
half the weight
three or four times the power like way
more fierce way more sporty um
easier to transport easier to get in and
out of
easier to learn and now that he's proven
what's possible he set his sights on the
sporting world
think about a cross between battlebots
and the world's strongest man
competitions a mech racing league where
athletes overcome obstacles and solve
physical puzzles without the violence of
course
beyond that who knows you could use them
in all sorts of applications
mining agriculture search and rescue
disaster response
um
forestry you know the sky's the limit a
mech suit is about as useful as a human
but amplified 50 times and just imagine
the potential when he figures out how to
build opposable thumbs
microlight global news toronto
next generation will be iron man i think
and that's global national for this
wednesday night i'm farah nasser and on
behalf of our whole team here i wanted
to thank you so much for spending part
of your evening with us tonight's your
canada is this pot of pelicans at a e
wilson park in regina we love seeing
your canada so please keep emailing us
your pictures to viewers at
globalnational.com
until i see you tomorrow take care of
yourselves and each other good night
[Music]
you